35 some breaking news now nate was
addressing this a few moments ago there
is some police activity happening right
now on hualapai near sahara that's right
so bianca holmen joining us now live at
the scene with the very latest of bianca
give us an update i understand this
scene is wrapping up
yes it is heather you can still see
crime tape up blocking the area that is
right in front of the dotties and also
right next door to an apartment complex
where this barricade took place it
actually took place at the stone ridge
community and
inside the community they told they tell
us metro tells us that it happened on
jasper bluff street now we don't know
the cause of this barricade situation
but this area has been blocked off for a
while several metro vehicles have left
the scene so it is clearing up but there
still are officers on scene here right
in front of the dotties even though it
didn't happen in front of the dotties it
actually happened at the community right
next door so once we learn more details
we will keep you updated here on air and
online we are waiting to find out what
caused the barricade but we do know that
the suspect is in police custody right
now and there were no injuries that were
reported bianca holman live local now